all right welcome to mama's sugar bags
y'all ready to order yeah
can i have a chicken fried steak with
gravy and a cola
i will have the baked beef short ribs
with collard greens
and throw down some of that cornbread
all right babe
you know what hold up a second i'm also
going to have some of them collard
greens and cornbread as well but hook a
brother up with some of them hot looks
all right all right
you know what uh what am i trying to
front scratch all that
give me some okra and some fried red
snapper
and girl you know i want some chilies
all right man
y'all got ham hocks of course well
that's what i want i want to play the
ham hocks
deep fried blackened and served on a bed
of mustard greens pig feet
i want some pig feet and four pounds of
grits
and oh oh and you know what else give me
a little dixie cup full of lard
all right i just remember what i want a
bowl of mosquitoes
none of them tiny ones either give me
them big [ __ ] to find down at
the swamp